Brazilians continue to dig mass graves
to bury their dead in Manaus the largest
city in the Brazilian Amazon the rows of
crosses are a visual reminder of the
heavy toll the coronavirus has taken in
the country Brazil now has the
second-highest kovat 19 death toll in
the world an unenviable position with
both daily fatalities and new infections
mounting the World Health Organization
says the country is certainly under
pressure but not yet overwhelmed the
situation in Brazil is of concern the
all 27 areas are affected we've seen
different rates of infection there are
clear hotspots and heavily populated
areas there are clearly differential
impacts in different populations we've
seen the impact in Amazonas but overall
the health system is still coping in
Brazil the pandemic is far from slowing
in the country and the death toll is
thought to be much higher than reported
but Brazil has started loosening
restrictions and reopening the economy
and the other Janeiro and Sao Paulo
the streets were busy on Friday as
shopping malls were allowed to welcome
customers again the loosening of
restrictions was championed by far-right
President Chad Wilson ro who has played
down the pandemic calling it a little
flu and claimed that the lockdown has
been worse than the disease
but experts say the country isn't yet
ready to reopen safely testing capacity
is lagging and a contact tracing system
hasn't been set up the fear is that a
hasty return to normal may further
worsen Brazil's dire coronavirus record
let's get more now from Michael Foxy's
of freelance journalists in Brazil and
joining me from the southern city of
florianópolis Michael thanks for joining
us let's get into these numbers a little
bit 42,000 is the official number but it
may be quite higher and at the same time
the lockdown measures are easing so to
get into more of that forest please
that's right according to two recent
study the real figure because of
underreporting and a lack of testing the
real figure could be as much as seven
times higher in terms of none of them
number infected right and the deaths it
could be much higher as well it's an
extremely extremely complicated moment
and like you said they're now starting
to reopen economy Sao Paulo is the main
place that we've been watching just over
this last week yesterday they started to
reopen stores shopping malls are now
open for reduced periods of time and of
course there are safety measures there
they have to be taking people's
temperatures people can only be in
certain certain stores or a certain
number of people but it's also created
these queues outside the stores for
people waiting to get inside some of the
streets are packed like we have not seen
in Sao Paulo in almost three months it's
extremely concerning because of course
the country hasn't hit peak yet we're
still far from it in fact the number of
people infected with the virus has
doubled in just two weeks
so we're likely to see those numbers
continue to rise and many people are
really nervous and yet at the same time
the World Health Organization is saying
that the health system is coping I'm
sure that's probably good news to
president bolson are oh is that what
you're seeing yeah so that's been one of
the things that we've been seeing for
long period of time it's important to
put this into context so the health
system in Brazil is a universal public
health system it's spread around the
country roughly 70% of the population at
least 70% the population uses it it is
not equally spread around the country
and that's been one of the the most
complicated things is the north and
northern northeastern part of the
country the more poorest part of the
country that area the health system is
not as robust and those the areas where
we've seen the health system come near
collapse and that's why we've seen
lockdowns implemented in cities like san
luis Fortaleza bedlam just over the last
month
now those lockdowns have been lifted in
recent weeks because what what they've
been doing is as soon as the health
system gets almost near collapsed and
they throw on the lockdown
european-style lockdown people cannot
leave their homes without you know
possible fines and things like that so
they've started to lift those up and
that's really helped those regions and
so at this point the health is amiss
still maintaining and that's the most
important thing but we don't know what
this is going to look like within
another month or another two months all
right Michael Fox reporting from
florianópolis in Brazil thank you very
much